CEO will always consider the safety and  the security of British nationals  so with immediate effect I've taken the  decision to advise British nationals  against non-essential travel globally  for an initial period of 30 days and of  course subject to ongoing review now Mr  Speaker I should emphasize this decision  has been taken based on the domestic  measures introduced here in the UK  alongside the changes to border and a  range of other restrictions which are  now being taken by countries right  around the world the speed and the range  of those measures across other countries  is unprecedented some of those decisions  are being made without notice  in some countries even in countries or  particular areas where there haven't yet  been any reported cases of covert 19  local authorities are nonetheless  imposing restrictions on movement and  again doing so with little or sometimes  no notice whatsoever